oh I'm someone from from I don't me go
first
[Music]
Fiona Fiona Shrek this how you supposed
to be not supposed to look I'm looking
for my walk oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
the makeup it flies and sweet
hey bud go away you [ __ ] I will not be
drinking my milk how dare you you wench
go again go Brian would you change my
nappy oh and Steve Stewie
how do one sees money is money money
I should go where um don't get
comfortable our dance now of it money
moves and Diet got it
yeah someone give me scone you must
listen to me Harry
hurry hurry the thing is I feel so bad
because I know this but I don't know I'm
not even say yeah I'm not I don't sound
like the guy I don't look like the guy
but I'm saying he talks to this person
and I'm saying the guy's name here we go
again
yes it's just his face how are me ideas
okay he's names kind of like a bird I'm
thinking this game last night show raise
the captain oh oh I'm on the GC I mean
like I won't have that and this is vegan
now cuz I'm just turned vegan do you not
I mean
it's listen babe babe if you don't get
this you're gonna be in big trouble you
know I mean there's a girl right no it's
not a guy we're talking about
I'm the GC I can't believe you haven't
got this this is ridiculous no no that
you see the GC bloody hell Ashley waters
I don't know you what we'll do Papagena
oh I'm someone from famous boxes
watching movies
[Applause]
you